the fourth Target is Major Xander
displaying a large number of anger
management issues she has been torturing
and interrogating civilians throughout
Washington DC
though it is unclear what she is
searching for she can't be allowed to
continue this Inquisition
[Music]
[Music]
Amanda Zander only wanted one thing in
life the opportunity to become a police
officer it's all that she had ever
really dreamed of the desire to uphold
the law and an eagerness to bring
Justice and order to the people
she possessed a high level of dedication
and skill in her work in the narcotic
sector and nothing felt better to her
than identifying a potential Target and
hunting them down
the police work wasn't all that she
thought it would crack up to be as most
of the time it was a waiting game filled
with endless paperwork and copious
amounts of cream-filled donuts
she knew she had to find other means of
entertainment to make up for a
lackluster career so she joined a
competitive shooting league
yet Xander was still not content with
her situation
she could be a dangerous person at the
best of times and especially when she
was bored she knew it her family knew it
and recently due to the use of excessive
force on a perpetrator now her superiors
knew it too
unsurprisingly as a result she was
sanctioned
she was anointed herself and she knew
she had to get back on track and channel
her impulsiveness into something else
there was still so much Glory out there
for her to grasp and she knew that
alarming her superiors so early on in
her career was not the way she was going
to get it
in order to help her direct her energy
into something more constructive her
commanding officer recommended that she
sign up for the National Guard
The Hope was that the intense training
schedule strict rules and very little
downtime would help curb for impulsive
and trigger finger nature
however a month later the devastating
green poison was delivered onto the
unsuspecting Shoppers of New York City
on Black Friday and from then on
everything for Xander would change
she along with a number of other
Personnel were placed on active duty
with the jtf and it was here that a man
by the name of Antoine Ridgeway would
become her commanding officer
here in this environment Xander's
Psychopathic traits of anti-social
Behavior lack of empathy disregard for
others and narcissism thrived
her callousness was praised her
impulsativity was considered charming
and a notable lack of guilt was an asset
Xander had finally found a place in the
world working for the future leader of
the true Sons
during the events of the Barton Schaefer
Manhunt Xander like many other true Sons
Blaine Schaefer for the loss of dusk
stand while you're angry but we need to
put a pin in this and focus on our
common enemy agent Lao I [ __ ] hate
that [ __ ] I don't trust her she's been
on my list for a while not Lau she's not
the enemy she turned you into her [ __ ]
boy you should hate her she has her
reasons
this channel is not secure but you
should really talk to Lau [ __ ] that I'm
not letting her get into my head
shaver has been discussing what's
happening behind the scenes with Faye
for a while now and he appears to be on
board
he now seems to be trying to reach out
to others to help in this fight against
the true enemy the Zender stubbornness
will require a different approach
[Music]
is that what this is about you hate loud
because you think we're together no I
hate Lao because that [ __ ] got half of
my squad killed in New York when the
reservists were called up to maintain
the quarantine oh
well good
I'd hate to think you were so pissed
about how things ended with us doesn't
help that you're sleeping with a traitor
okay she's not a traitor she's a good
woman she's been through a lot we all
have
just give her a chance meet with her and
you'll see we can help each other
there's something bigger happening
to getting married would it matter if we
were damn okay Douglas you need me to go
rescue your Pappy from the White House
you're gonna finally reconcile so he can
walk you down the aisle is that the
secret mission Xander Focus we need to
work together if we're going to stop
what's coming okay fine
set it up
I'll meet with Lao
Bridget Douglas AKA Viper would later be
a part of feylau's team in the following
Manhunt
Viper was the only child of Charles
Douglas the co-founder of the Douglas
and Harding military equipment company
though they weren't particularly close
and after the outbreak Charles now
resides in the White House acting as the
range officer
Viper was an unactivated shd agent who
instead ended up joining the Black Tusk
where she would later meet agent Lau
Xander and Viper having previously been
in a relationship opened up
communications between Faye Schaefer and
the true Sons where they appear to be
recruiting for a future operation
as a side note I really must bring up
the relationship between Faye and Viper
although this isn't of any particular
significance towards the story other
than linking all of these characters
together it's more that I've been
getting a hard time at home from my wife
because she absolutely called it way
back when the feylau Manhunt was going
on but I uh I didn't agree or include it
in the video I need to remember the wife
is always right so uh yeah my bad
regardless this recruiting attempt would
end up being unsuccessful Xander would
inform General Anderson who would then
get in contact with Natalia Circle over
but as we now know fans out there
working under her own agenda so Natalia
has no idea what he's talking about
I do wish you would reconsider my kind
offer and I wish you would reconsider
trying to recruit my men to whatever
clandestine [ __ ] you and Lauer
cooking up I don't have any idea what
you're talking about oh don't play dumb
it's not convincing on you if Raul is
reaching out to your true Sons it is not
on my orders that's on her own volition
or maybe it's your true sons that are
reaching out to her my troops are loyal
who did she allegedly reach out to Major
sander oh
well this is probably a personal matter
more than professional have you seen the
state of the world no one has time for
personal matters well women like Amanda
find a way to make the time
you don't have to worry no one is trying
to take her from you
she frankly would not be a good fit for
the Black Tusk even if she wasn't trying
to cast herself as the victim of a love
triangle just stay away from my troops
certainly General have a good day and
don't hesitate to call again if you need
anything
good luck managing Xander Douglas says
she can be a bit unstable
a little while later after Barton
Schaefer was captured by the division
and feylau was killed at Camp White Oak
major Xander was sent into Washington DC
with a team of true Sons
however after reports of her harsh
treatment of local civilians started
flooding in the division was sent out to
put a stop to her plans
on the Eastern side of DC they would
catch up with Xander in the Judiciary
Square District
after taking out a number of outposts
being held by the true Sons agents would
find her hunkered down in the district
Union Arena and while they would have
loved to be able to find out what Xander
was searching for there was no chance
that she would allow herself to be taken
alive
so piece by piece her true Sun soldiers
would be taken apart
and in a final stand she too would be
quickly taken down by the agents
another Target with relatively light
information but it does somewhat confirm
a few of the suspicions around the
direction Schaefer has been headed and
from quite early on though I like how a
lot of the previous characters are now
being linked together
however the true information we've been
gaining from this season has been
through phase insurance policy comms of
which I'll be talking about a little
later on
I have a system and a process in place
for these videos and they can take me a
little while to make so I apologize for
the wait but I should have the captain
Lewis one out in a couple of days and
from there I can get stuck into the
really interesting stuff
anyway thank you very much for watching
Once Again a special thanks to my
YouTube and patreon members
but I'll catch you soon in the next one
cheers
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]